hey guys it's Antony I'm here at
BuzzFeed and I'm gonna read your thirst
tweets and I'm also probably more
uncomfortable doing this than I could
possibly be at a hockey game
alright I'm so tracted to Anthony from
query I just want him to cook naked for
me and sensually shake my cocktails
cookie make it is dangerous especially
near an open flame maybe cutting
vegetables wouldn't be tempted no you do
not want to have your naked body next to
a knife wish Antony would rip me apart
like he did that giant lobster I don't
even know what to say to that
Antony could swim in my bussy and I
stand by that
what's a [ __ ] swim I just want to eat
pickled carrots off of Anthony's abs you
know what I appreciate specificity this
is a person who knows what they like you
know what else is good pickled okra and
pickled green beans and pickled
jalapenos but not when they're pickled
too long because then they get mushy and
brown I like you when they're crunchy
I wonder if pickling peas would be nice
I've never had pickled peas before
pickled shallots are really nice too I
would pay good money to suck oh okay
okay it wasn't as bad haha I would pay
good money to suck Antony's nipples I do
have very sensitive nipples it's been
documented on Instagram several times
thank you to tan France and Jonathan Van
Ness you're not off-brand whoever you
are
Antony really out here being the hottest
man to flip pancakes huh thank you
that's one of the nicest things anyone's
ever said about me I get wet anytime
Antony says like so I do say that a lot
apparently I say plop a lot as well plop
feels kind of sexual I know now I'm not
gonna be able to say it anymore it's
like I can't wear strokes t-shirts or
hold a corgi anymore because I just feel
like it's been like overdone and I like
saying like so because how do you do
things you do it like so you put the
tomato paste in your pot like so Yuji
glaze with wine like so it just makes
sense
mm-hmm I can't stop thinking about
Anthony's bulge I think about it
probably just as much as you do because
I am constantly adjusting it cuz I wear
very tight jeans anthony from queer i
could walk into the target shoes
and eat my entire ass would I be opposed
no he is free to do this if he chooses
and I encourage it actually the target
shoe section like from a tarjay that is
so weirdly specific it sounds like it
was like some kind of a weird dream and
what's this declaration would I be
opposed no look were you sharing this
with Antony could make an overrated PB&J
and I would still want to have sex with
it well you should because if PB&J is
fantastic as long as you get the peanut
butter in the jam all the way to the
sides and as long as you toast it don't
be lazy use a toaster you want to get a
crunchy well that's it's like a really
fresh brioche or if it's like a baguette
or like a nice a nice a nice loaf that
already has a crust but if you're using
like your Wonder Bread or an equivalent
or like a nice Japanese milk bread I
love milk bread then you definitely want
to toast it except if the milk bread is
really fresh and then you cut the crusts
off I don't remember what the tweet was
I want Antony to feed me deviled eggs
shirtless in the bedroom of our luxury
New York apartment while we laugh about
our childhoods same hit me up Antony is
so fine WTF I wonder if he'd have a
threesome with me and another guy or
I'll just watch it's up to him
thank you for being so open-minded can't
believe queer eyes only rated tv-14 when
the slowed down close shots of Antony's
hands cooking in each episode are actual
porn I'm always holding a knife and that
feels very dangerous
I guess knives are weirdly sexual aren't
they it's like being choked some of us
like it but we know it's dangerous but
if you like choking make sure you have a
safe word actually and that's the hard
way about to have some TM I don't have a
safe word have a safe move because often
you can't speak if you're being choked
protip you're welcome for that one kids
thanks so much
if you want to make some delicious food
and see a bunch of photos of me wearing
clothes please by Anthony in the kitchen
and make a dish for someone special
today thanks guys
[Music]